it's an ongoing problem across the
country and we've seen plenty of it here
in the valley as well catalytic
converter theft now the Nevada
legislature is taking action with two
separate bills to stop it Madison
Kimbrough has more on what some say
about whether these potential bills will
hump things move forward
for those that may not know catalytic
converters are part of a vehicle's
exhaust system like the one that you see
right here many contain precious metals
making them worth stealing the second
one that was stolen was actually at the
U-Haul lot
and that's what was so you know so
disheartening secret Williams sharing
with 8 news now her own experience with
catalytic converter theft you may recall
Williams has been on eight before we
shared her story when two of her
catalytic converters were stolen from
her church and this past week the Nevada
legislature proposing two bills that
would combat the theft the first removes
catalytic converters from the list of
scrap metals and defines offenses as
felonies in addition allows law
enforcement to presume that anyone in
possession of two or more catalytic
converters likely stole them unless they
are an authorized dealer also it assigns
prison time based on the degree of the
offense the second Bill Dives deeper
into the fines that repeat offenders
could face
Erica Delgadillo with Sahara Muffler and
catalytic converter repair says she sees
people on a daily basis coming in and so
these proposed bills is a step in the
right direction the legislation it's
good it's good because they've been
taking a while they've been taking a
while to do that but I mean finally
they're doing it I mean we know it's not
going to 100 eliminate the problem but
at least you know the people out there
stealing them they're going to be aware
that they're going to be a bad
consequence for them and for those who
have fallen victim to it like sequet
agree I think that anything
that's going to kind of deter people
from just taking catalytic converters
and selling them you know is a step in
the right direction certainly it could
have helped us locally North Las Vegas
has already passed an ordinance making
it harder for criminals to sell and
transfer catalytic converters consisting
of up to six months in jail and up to a
thousand dollar fine if found with one
illegally reporting near Sahara and lamb
Madison Kimbrough 8 news now if you're
worried about being a Target those over
at Sahara Muffler and catalytic
converter repair tell us installing
cages around your catalytic converter
help prevent these sorts of thefts